in the world of cryptography storing
data in plain text is the biggest risk
an organization can take
from a consumer point of view we prefer
our data to be encrypted at all points
be it during transit or at rest
hashing has provided to be quite
beneficial in this regard since the
early 90s and still finds use when
storing critical data
today we will cover the technical
aspects of hashing while going through
some well-known hash functions and
algorithms at the end
let's take a look at the topics we are
covering today
we start by learning about cryptography
in general and its various applications
historical significance and categories
we also have a demonstration of how
cryptography is used in today's industry
when encrypting internet traffic
we follow that up by taking a deep dive
on to hashing
we cover the basics of hashing like hash
functions guidelines ways to strengthen
hashes among other things
next we cover the md5 hash algorithm
explaining the steps taken when
scrambling the data and checking out
applications and advantages
finally we also cover the sha hash
algorithm its phases during hashing and
the distinct advantages over other
algorithms of this nature
with the rise in censorship and general
fear over privacy loss consumer security
is at an all-time high risk technology
has made our life so much easier while
putting up a decent target on our
personal information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
safeguard our data
and be up to date with the latest
technological developments maintaining
this balance has become easier with
cryptography taking its place in today's
digital world
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography
meet ann
ann wanted to look for a decent discount
on the latest iphone she started
searching on the internet and found a
rather shady website that offered a 50
discount on the first purchase
once and submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http webpage instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employees cryptography
our iphone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them
now that we understand why cryptography
is so important
let's now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text
to encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on whatsapp every day
all of which are secured thanks to end
to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now
do you remember the difference between a
cipher and ciphertext
leave your answers in the comments and
before we proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster
it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
caesar cipher enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example
if alice wants to send a message to bob
she can apply a substitution cipher or a
shift cipher to encrypt the message but
bob must be aware of the same key itself
so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into cipher text
stream ciphers convert the plain text
into cipher text one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available
other primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of aes
aes chops ups the data into blocks and
performs 10 plus rounds of obscuring and
substituting the message to make it
unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post transit if alice wants to
communicate with bob using asymmetric
encryption
she encrypts the message using bob's
public key
after receiving the message bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data this
way nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information rsa encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its founders
reversed xiaomi and adelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than aes it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time
since asymmetric encryption takes longer
to decrypt large amounts of data the
full information is encrypted using a
single key that is symmetric encryption
that single key is then transmitted to
the receiver using asymmetric encryption
so you don't have to compromise either
way another route is using the
diffie-hellman key exchange which relies
on a one-way function and is much
tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general
the calculations that do the job of
messing up the data collection form the
hash function
they are generally not reversible
without resilient brute force mechanisms
and are very helpful when storing data
on website servers that need not be
stored in plain text
for example many websites store your
account passwords in a hashed format so
that not even the administrator can read
your credentials when a user tries to
log in they can compare the entered
passwords hash value with the hash value
that is already stored on the servers
for authentication since the function
will always return the same value for
the same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2 a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes dw
defn
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we received the same plain text
message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of rsa encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know rsa encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message
there are some occasions when this
allocation is reversed and we will have
a look at them as well
in rsa we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on pass phrases the tool we
are using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation
once we generate the keys you can see
the public key is rather smaller than
the private key which is almost always
the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here
let's select the same
and copy it and paste over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain rsa there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once we click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plaintext will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from brute force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement
he or she must already possess the
private key generated from the same pair
no other private key can be used to
decrypt the message since they are
mathematically linked
we paste the private key here and select
the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once you click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of rsa encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
wrong we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key
and use that to encrypt the plain text
and select the same in this checkbox as
well
you can see we have generated a
completely new cipher text
this cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the h stands for
secured
let's take a look at how it secures that
data
wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use the software to
see the traffic that is leaving a
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched
similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a http web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks
there is a login form here which needs
legitimate user credentials in order to
grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform
instead we can see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
http login form to the internet
if we check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or legitimate credentials it
would have been really easy to get a
hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid http
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
imagine creating an account on a new
website
you provide your email address and set a
password that you are confident
and you would not forget
what about the website owner how
securely are they going to store your
password
for website administrators they have
three alternatives they can either store
the passwords in a plain text format
they can encrypt the passwords using an
encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value
let's have a look at each of these
when a password is stored in plain text
format it is considered to be the most
unsafe option since anyone in the
company can view your passwords a single
hack and a data server breach will
expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra effort
to counter this owners can encrypt the
passwords and keep them in the servers
as a second alternative
but that would mean they also have to
store the decryption key somewhere on
their servers
in the event of a data breach or the
server hack both the decryption key and
encrypted passwords will be leaked thus
making it a single point of failure
what if there was an option to store the
passwords after scrambling them
completely but with no way to decrypt
them
this is where hashing comes to play
since only the hashed values are stored
in the server
though encryption is needed with no
plain text passwords to protect your
credentials are safe from the website
administrators
considering all the pros cached
passwords are the industry standard when
it comes to storing credentials nowadays
before getting too deep into the topic
let's get a brief overview of how
hashing works
is the process of scrambling a piece of
information or data beyond recognition
we can achieve this by using hash
functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plaintext information through the hash
function is called the hash value digest
or in general just the hash of the
original data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are made to be irreversible no
decryption key can convert a digest back
to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in news among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification etc
like we discussed earlier websites use
hashing to store the user's passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function and the resulting hash
value is stored on the servers
so the next time a user comes to login
to the account the password he enters is
passed through the same hash function
and compared to the hash stored on the
main server
if the newly calculated hash is the same
as the one stored on the website server
the password must have been correct
because according to hash functions
terminology same inputs will always
provide the same outputs
if the hashes do not match then the
password entered during login is not the
same as the password entered during the
sign up hence the login will be denied
this way no plain text passwords get
stored preventing both the owner from
snooping on user data and protecting
users privacy in the unfortunate event
of a data breach or a hack
apart from password storage hashing can
also be used to perform integrity checks
when a file is uploaded on the internet
the files hash value is generated and it
is uploaded along with the original
information
when a new user downloads the file he
can calculate the digest of the
downloaded file using the same hash
function
when the hash values are compared if
they match then file integrity has been
maintained and there has been no data
corruption
since so much important information is
being passed on to the hash function we
need to understand how they work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations operated on two blocks of
data
the main input is broken down into two
blocks of similar size
the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being used
hash functions are designed to be one
way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by design
some algorithms like the previously
mentioned md5 have been compromised but
most secure algorithms are being used
today like the sha family of algorithms
the digest size is also dependent on the
respective algorithm being used
md5 has a digest of 128 bits while she
256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively fast pace
but it also shouldn't be very fast
running the algorithm on all cylinders
makes the functions easy to boot force
and a security liability
there must be a balance to allow the
hash function to handle large amounts of
data and not make it ridiculously easy
to brute force by running through all
the possible combinations
the hash function must be dependent on
each bit of the input
the input can be text audio video or any
other file extension
if a single character is being changed
it doesn't matter how small that
character may be the entire digest must
have a distinctly different hash value
this is essential to create unique
digests for every password that is being
stored
but what if two different users are
using the same password
since the hash function is the same for
all users both the digest will be the
same
this is called a hash collision
you may think this must be a rare
occasion where two users have exactly
the same password but that is not the
case
we have techniques like salting that can
be used to reduce these hash collisions
as we will discuss later in this video
you would be shocked to see the most
used passwords of 2020.
all of these passwords are laughably
insecure and since many people use the
same passwords repeatedly on different
websites hash collisions risk are more
common than one would expect
let's say the hash functions find two
users having the same password
how can they store both the hashes
without messing up the original data
this is where salting and peppering come
to play
salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function
this random keyword is unique for each
user on the system and it is called the
salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the salt value will differ and so
will they digest
there is a small problem in this process
though
since the salt is unique for each user
they need to be stored in the database
along with the passwords and sometimes
even in plain text to speed up the
process of continuous verification
if the server is hacked then the hashes
will need to be brute forced which takes
a lot of time but if they receive the
salts as well the entire process becomes
very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case
the paper isn't stored on the servers it
is mostly hard coded onto the website
source code since it's going to be the
same for all credentials
this way even if the servers get hacked
they will not have the right pepper
needed to crack into all the passwords
many websites use a combination of
salting and peppering to solve the
problem of hash collision and bolster
security
since brute force takes such a long time
many hackers avoid taking the effort the
returns are mostly not worth it and the
possible combinations of using both
salting and peppery is humongous
with the consensus aiming towards an
educated public on digital privacy it's
no surprise to see an increasing
interest in encryption algorithms
we have already covered the major names
like the des and the aes algorithm
md5 algorithm was one of the first
hashing algorithms to take the global
stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 still
remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments
the md5 hashing algorithm is a one-way
cryptographic functions that accepts a
message of any length as input and it
returns as output a fixed length digest
value to be used for authenticating the
original messages
the digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input
the md5 hash function was originally
designed for use as a secure
cryptographic hash algorithm to
authenticate digital signatures
md5 has also been depreciated for uses
other than as a non-cryptographic
checksum to verify data integrity and
detect unintentional data corruption
ronald rivest founder of rsa data
security and institute professor at mit
designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the md4
as already iterated before the process
is straightforward we pass our plain
text message to the md5 hash functions
which in turn performs certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 128-bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the plain text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digests that appear to be
random
to be considered cryptographically
secure
the hash functions should meet two
requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value
even a slight change in the plaintext
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which take place when two
different plain texts have the same
digest
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the rises
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when we receive the input string we have
to make sure the size is 64 bit short of
a multiple of 512.
when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters
this prepares the string to have a
length of just 64 bits less than any
multiple of 512.
here on out we can proceed on to the
next step where we have to pad the
length bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
length of the bits in the message was 64
bit short of any multiple of 512.
now we add the length bits in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message is perfectly a multiple of 512.
that means 64-bit lens to be precise are
added to the message
our final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of 512.
the next step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer
the entire hashing plain text is now
broken down into 512 bit blocks
there are four buffers or registers that
are of 32 bits each named a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these sub
blocks
the first iteration to follow these
registers will have fixed hexadecimal
values as shown on the screen below
once these values are initial
of these 512 blocks we can divide each
of them into 16 further sub blocks of 32
bits each
for each of these sub blocks we run four
rounds of operations having the four
buffer variables a b c and d
these rounds require the other constant
variables as well which differ with each
round of operation
the constant values are stored in a
random array of 64 elements
since each 32-bit sub-block is run 4
times 16 such sub-blocks equal 64
constant values needed for a single
block iteration
the sub-blocks can be denoted by the
alphabet m and the constant values are
denoted by the alphabet t
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration
at the very beginning the values of
buffers b c and d are passed on to a
non-linear logarithmic function
the formula behind this function changes
by the particular round being worked on
as we shall see later in this video
once the output is calculated it is
added to the raw values stored in buffer
a
the output of this addition is added to
the particular 32-bit sub-block using
which we are running the four operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value derived from the constant array k
since we have
four different elements in the array
repeat
since we have 64 different elements in
the array we can use a distinct element
for each iteration of a particular block
the next step involves a circular shift
that increases the complexity of the
hash algorithm and is necessary to
create a unique digest for each
individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer b
the final output is now stored in the
second buffer of b of the output
register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in c
value of c get stored in d and the value
of d in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this sub block the values of a abcd
are moved on as input to the next
sub-block
once all 16 sub-blocks are completed the
final register value is saved and the
next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5 algorithm
regarding the non-linear process
mentioned in the first step the formula
changes for each round it is being run
on this is done to maintain the
computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure
the formula for each of the four rounds
uses the same parameters that is b c and
d to generate a single output the
formulas being used are shown on the
screen right now
algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digest
they don't consume a noticeable amount
of disk storage and are comparatively
easier to remember and reiterate
passwords need not be stored in plain
text format making them accessible for
hackers and malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
the hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which should
be the user passwords in this case
since the functions are irreversible by
design hashing has become a compulsion
when storing user credentials on the
server nowadays
a relatively low memory footprint is
necessary when it comes to integrating
multiple services into the same
framework without a cpu overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string
this helps in creating a low requirement
for computational power and is much
easier to run on older hardware which is
pretty common in server farms around the
world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and we can avoid data
corruption
hash functions will always give the same
output for the similar input
irrespective of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message
we use our wi-fi every day for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication
the dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades
a big portion of this belongs to
ensuring secure channels of
communication and data transmission
the secure hash algorithm are a family
of cryptographic hash functions that are
published by the national institute of
standards and technology along with the
nsa
it was passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as fips
it has four different families of hash
functions ssj0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw
sha-1 is also a 160-bit hash function
which resembles the earlier md5
algorithm
this was designed by the nsa to be a
part of the digital signature algorithm
scga2 is a family of two similar hash
functions with different block sizes
known as the sha-256 and the sha-512
they differ in the word size
she-256 uses 32-bit words while sha-512
uses 64-bit words
ssh 3 is a hash function properly known
as kcac it was chosen in 2012 after a
public competition among non-nsa
designers
it supports the same hash lengths as hj2
and its internal structure differs
significantly from the rest of the sha
family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sha hash function which
in turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data
the 160 bit digest received from this is
going to be radically different from the
plain text
the goal of any hash function is to
produce digests that appear to be random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash function should meet two
requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value
and second it should be impossible for
an attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plain text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which takes place when two
different plain texts have the same
digest
the sha family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the digest
let's go through a few of them
the length of the clear text should be
less than 2 to the power 64 bits in the
case of sha-1 and sh-256
this is essential to keep the plain text
compatible with the hash function and
the size needs to be in comparison area
to keep the digest as random as possible
the length of the hash digest should be
256 bits in the sha-256 algorithm 512
bits in the sha 512 algorithm and so on
bigger digest usually suggests
significantly more calculations at the
cost of speed and space
we typically go for the longest digest
to bolster security but there must be a
definite balance between the speed and
security of a hash function
by design all hash function of the sha
512 she-256
are irreversible
you should neither get a plain text when
you have the digest beforehand
nor should the digest provide the
original value when you pass it through
the same hash function again another
case of protection is that when the hash
digest is passed into the sha function
for a second time we should get a
completely different digest from the
first instance
this is done to reduce the chance of
brute force attacks
to achieve this level of intricacy there
are a number of steps to be followed
before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the sha algorithm
works
the first step is to make the plain text
compatible with the hash function
to do this we need to pad the bits in
the message
when you receive the input string you
have to make sure the size is 64 bit
short of a multiple of 512
when it comes to padding the bits you
must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares a string to have a length
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512
here on out we can proceed to the next
step where we have to pad the length
bits
initially in the first step we appended
the message in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message was 64 bit
short from becoming a multiple of 512.
now we add the length of bits in such a
way that the total number of bits in the
message is a perfect multiple of 512.
that means 64 bits plus the length of
the original message becomes a multiple
of 512. this becomes a final string that
needs to be hashed
in the next step we have to initialize
this chaining variables
the entire plain text message can now be
broken down into blocks of 512 bits each
unlike other hash algorithms like md5
which use 4 registers or buffers sha
family use 5 buffers of 32 bits each
they are named a b c d and e these
registers go through multiple rounds of
operation but the first iteration has
fixed hexadecimal values as can be seen
in the screen
moving on we have to process each of the
512-bit blocks by breaking each of them
into 16 sub-blocks of 32 bits each
each of them goes through 4 rounds of
operation that use the entire register
and have the 512-bit block along with a
constant array out of those four rounds
each round has 20 iterations so in
general we have 80 rounds sum total
the constant value of k is an array of
80 elements
of those 80 16 elements are being used
each round so that comes out to 80
rounds for each of those elements
the value of t differs by the number of
rounds as can be seen in the table below
a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration
the formula can be a b c d e register is
equal to e plus a non-linear process b
along with a circular shift of a plus w
t plus kt
in this formula abcd is the register
value of the chaining variables as we
discussed before
p is the logical process which has a
different formula for each round
s5 is a circular shift by 5 bits
and wt is a 32-bit string derived from
the existing sub-block this can be
calculated depending on the iteration at
hand
kt signifies a single element of the 80
character element array which changes
depending on the particular round at
hand
for the values of wt the first 16 values
are the same as that of the sub blocks
so there is no extra calculation needed
for the next 64 elements the value of wt
can be calculated as shown in the
formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have an initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output
next we use a non-linear process b that
changes depending on the round and uses
the values of b c and d as input
whatever output is generated from the
non-linear process it is added with the
value of the e register
next the value of a is circular shifted
by 5 bits and is added with the output
generated in the previous step
the next step is adding the value of wt
and the constant element of kt the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
sub-block in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
sub-blocks are joined together to form
the single ciphertext message we will
have our hashed output regarding the
non-linear process p that uses the
values of b c and d as input
the formula changes every round to
maintain a complexity of the program
that can withstand brute force attacks
depending on the round the values are
passed through a logical operation which
is then added with the values of wt kt
and so on
now that we understand how to get our
hash digest from the plain text let us
learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text format
digital signatures follow asymmetric
encryption methodology to verify the
authenticity of a document or a file
hash algorithms like ssh 256 and the
industry standard sha 512 go a long way
in ensuring the verification of
signatures
passwords need not be stored in a plain
text format which makes them accessible
to hackers and other malicious actors
when using digest the database security
also gets a boost since the size of all
hash values will be the same
in the event of a hack or a breach the
malicious actor will only receive the
hash values with no way to regenerate
the plain text
in this case the plain text would be
user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers
the ssl handshake is a crucial segment
of the web browsing sessions and it's
done using sha functions
it consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection
it relies on a combination of symmetric
and asymmetric algorithms which ensure
the confidentiality of the data
transmitted between a web server and a
web client like the browsers
you can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
transit
once the hashes match file integrity
checks are valid and data corruption is
avoided
hash functions will always give the same
output for the same input irrespective
of the iteration parameters
it also helps in ensuring that the data
hasn't been tampered with on route to
the receiver of the message
hope you learned something new today if
you have any questions from today's
session be sure to let us know in the
comments below
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this thank you for watching